hi in this video I will talk about
regulation of g-protein signaling now
here is an overview of g-protein
signaling g-protein signaling could be
of different kinds for example G is
signaling in GS signaling the trimeric
g-protein in the alpha subunit of the
trimeric g-proteins get dissociated from
the gpcr upon ligand binding and that
actually activates adenylate cyclase and
which leads to cyclic GMP generation and
thereby activation of protein kinase a
and subsequent trust transcription of
genes from the nucleus another signaling
is GQ signaling which involves
phospholipase c and cleavage of pip2 and
it generates ip3 ip3
binds to our pitch free receptor on the
ER and allow calcium influx from the ER
and that activates protein kinase c and
there were subsequent signaling happens
so beta G Q signaling or RGS signaling g
proteins work like a molecular switches
they have two configurations and on and
off in a gdp bound state they are in a
off situation but from the off situation
one nucleotide exchange factors can
change their configuration and exchange
gtp and thereby activating them now gtp
bound g protein is activated whereas a
gtp is activating protein or gaps can
switch off these G proteins or switch
off the cheap protein signaling and get
them back hydrolyze the gtp and get them
back to a gdp-bound inactive state now
beta JQ signaling or a GS signaling our
GS is one of the common regulator which
which have a gap activity since it has a
gap activity or gtp as activator
like activity so it can hydrolyze gtp
from both G alpha s or G alpha Q C G
alpha cube modules and thereby
terminating the downstream signaling
further now upon prolonged agony
stimulation or prolong ligand based
stimulation another interesting way of
terminating the g-protein signaling is
receptor internalization when ligand
binds to the GPS here for a long time
there are certain kindnesses which can
phosphorylate GPCRs and the
phosphorylated GPCR is actually binding
site for PT arresting beta arrestin can
in turn interact with adaptor proteins
like a p2 and which bringing clattering
could assembly and once
clattering coat is assembled the gpcr is
endocytosed now the GP s-- here in the
site assists in a clattering dependent
manner he is one of the important ways
by which receptor desensitization could
occur once cheap protein was
internalized it would form a into zone
in an induced own state it can stay in
the cytosol for minutes to hours now it
could have two different faiths either
it could be recycled back to the
membrane or it could be degraded by
fusion with a lysosome now not only
actually based endocytosis is the
mechanism of g-protein internalization
it has been also seen that G proteins
are associated with lipid rafts so they
are also whole localized with caviar
even some of the time
that's why capilla mediated endocytosis
is another mechanism of g-protein
signaling termination or receptor
desensitization now complexity of the
g-protein signaling comes from a
combinatorial phosphorylation code and
it is entirely dependent upon which
kinase
phosphorylates which residue of the
g-protein for example GRK -
phosphorylated specific serine residues
on the GPCR c-terminal domain whereas
grk seeks phosphorylates a different set
of residues on the c-terminal domain of
the GPCR now these different pattern of
phosphorylation works like a barcode
each particular pattern of
phosphorylation has a specific meaning
do it that could be laid by specific
barcode reader in the cell for example
beta arrestin can read this kind of
differential phosphorylation and
depending upon the phosphorylation
pattern it leads to different fate for
example GRK - mediated phosphorylation
pattern could be led by Peter s team as
a result beta testing has a scaffolding
function which bring which bring a p2
and thereby clattering mediated
endocytosis occurs also in case of GR
k-6 mediated phosphorylation pattern
when when beta arrestin reads this bad
pattern how many different scenario
happens then beta RS team works like a
signalling hub it brings him SRC kinase
and thereby SRC kinase interacts with R
and a map kinase signaling cascade
occurs so depending upon this
phosphorylation barcode different sort
of regulation could occur now another
form of long-lasting mechanism by which
cheese protein signaling could be
terminated is down regulation of the
GPCR transcript itself so since the gpcr
is actually on the surface as at a
protein level and it has to be recycled
back and new GPCR should be formed which
would be displayed on the surface
so now after prolonged Nirvana
stimulation
in order to reduce the signaling less
amount of GPCR could be produced and
this kind of phenomena has been reported
in mouse or factory with helium when
Mouse effect Mouse olfactory system is
stimulated with prolonged overexposure
then most of the cases it has been seen
gpcrs are down regulated in an order and
concentration dependent manner so these
are the some most common type of
regulation that G protein undergoes and
thereby g-protein mediated signaling
could be highly regulated by these kind
of mechanisms I hope you enjoyed this
video if you like my video give me the
click thumbs up thank you